good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend again because she hasn't even
spoken one word about it which is so
weird your birthday's tomorrow
tomorrow
tomorrow
i love you
tomorrow
you're only
a day
sorry i don't want to turn off that many
people like we're one checking this is
triggering
that that was actually pretty good do
you think i have a shot at any live
well i don't know the bar is low so it's
possible
thank you that was really good thank you
so much claudia i've been working on my
craft thank you i know tomorrow is the
big day it's really like not to be one
of those girls that's like i'm not about
birthdays because you guys know that i
am and if you didn't get me a gift like
don't even look me in the eye
but it's just like an anti-climactic
birthday i'm turning 29 so it's neither
here nor there thank god it's not 30
jacks and i have more going on in my
life like more important things than
birthday things yeah so i'm just sort of
enjoying it you know it's going to be
extremely low key but i do still expect
the same caliber of present that you
would do for any birthday of course so
that's where i'm at i'm excited to you
know celebrate with my loved ones you
know you know what like birthdays can be
like depressing and i feel like okay
you're turning 29. you're pregnant
you're married you have a successful
business like there's really nothing
depressing about it no i'm feeling
extremely at peace i feel like i'm i'm
where i'm meant to be
and i'm looking forward to the future i
i am not one of those people that's like
getting older turning 28 again yeah you
know um are you checking away
you do have bring that energy sometimes
but i know that i just can't believe
like so much time has passed like since
i was just 21 you know yeah but i know
that that's not who you are and also
like you too are married have a
successful business you're only a mere
27th yeah but now it's like you're
getting into the birthdays where it's
like oh you don't have a child yeah
that's like the only thing that gives me
a pet
but i just don't want to no i mean
maybe but like nobody actually says that
and in this day and age like women are
having children later and later and i i
actually feel like there's more judgment
now if you have a child when you're
young versus yes no there's not more
judgment like i feel like there's more
like even like judgment for you getting
married so young oh yeah if you got
married at what 23
yes i feel like there's more judgment
for you getting married at 23 than there
would have been if you got married at
33. yeah no i think so too i get like so
much hate i'm like [ __ ] a whole lot i
feel like back then you did because but
now obviously you know you guys are
proof in the pudding but when i tell
people like their eyes like they really
are like like you were sold into a cult
and you were a child bride
which is crazy no and you know what i
actually was just listening on on my
tick tock it came up jc marie smith did
a podcast she got married really really
young and she was like
i would not recommend it she's like i'm
the lucky and you know what the way that
she described it was exactly how i feel
i'm like honestly i don't think it's
good to get married so young unless it's
me in bed and like you know you really
are like so immature and like you're
such a different person and there's a
possibility that like you outgrow each
other right or you just quickly when you
grow up you end up someone that your
partner doesn't like or your partner
ends up someone that you don't like and
so i actually think she did a real i
forget what podcast it was she did a
really good segment
no i feel like she was a guest on like a
deer media podcast okay and i just think
that like she was 100 right like thank
god things turned out the way that they
did but like they really could have
turned out the other way right but maybe
that's why you got married at 23 like
you knew that no matter who you turn
into and ben turns into like you guys
are there's no way to know there's
literally no way to know that there is a
way we all knew it but no one no but
like when you and them were getting
married like no one was like ooh
like you know
yes but i just um
you know the people that judge
they're not always wrong
yeah no i there is i'm yes but i'm
saying you heard we're good we're good
everything's good listen just focus on
yourselves yeah you know you don't need
to be looking to the left or to the
right as long as you're doing what you
want to be doing yeah i know i'm pretty
like happy in my life yeah so then and
are you coming up on this 29th birthday
i am i really i really i really am i'm
looking forward i'm looking forward to
what's next and that's why i'm just
cruising into your last birthday like by
yourself
yeah but then my next one is 30 so i'll
do something like really big and we'll
make up for the low penis of this one
you know like maybe like girls
like something crazy i'll plan it okay
cool i still don't have kids by then
probably um so that's exciting and then
i think i'm gonna get myself a little
gift and by little i mean enormous
enormous i have a bag in mind uh but i
think i should you know
peruse i like to get myself a birthday
gift just as you know it's an excuse to
get myself something that i've been
wanting ensuring that like all the gifts
you get this year there's at least one
you like yeah yeah but you know there's
always credits store credit did you see
that
chanel hiked up their prices like they
do every year but like i think i'm
seeing a lot of people talking about it
on tick tock it was like a pretty they
do it like with inflation and stuff like
but this one like
like the starting price for bags is like
insane i didn't see this particular one
but that makes sense it's a sign of the
times i mean and also they have nerve
with some of the [ __ ] they've come out
with recently no we're all we're all
shopping secondhand these days yeah no
but also it's like
then the the looks have to be there you
know you want to charge your premium the
looks have got to be there and you think
that they haven't i the last few times
i've been in the store like
it's not been great and they also don't
have anything on the shelves they have
no inventory like everything is still
backed up because of code covid and they
like barely even make anything well
because their bags are becoming
literally unaffordable i mean they were
never affordable but no but it's just
like the whole fashion supply chain is
just out of whack you know what i walked
past some of the big department stores
today they've sealed their windows
they're getting ready for holiday they
obviously heard yesterday's episode
which is so exciting like
you know what i was once again watching
the today show today not as good of an
episode um
but
the commercials on tv are all holiday
like so people are getting [ __ ] for
having their christmas trees up just
watch tv every single commercial
yesterday starbucks launched their
christmas drinks it's officially holiday
season so stop fighting it and just you
know feel deck the halls deck the halls
get with it fam get with it now are
those reezies or phasies these are
yeezys real ones real easys yeah good
for you thank you i have one pair of
rhys
and
they're extremely comfortable durable
and they match my outfit they're really
cute thanks it's such a friday outfit i
know like let's just talk about the
facts i know that it's friday it's a
friday of your birthday weekend we made
it through a full week we haven't been
in studio together for a full week in a
long time i'm partially responsible for
that um
actually fully responsible yeah i'm like
i've been here there are no
responsibilities
so yeah i hope everyone i'm just ready
to like go out with a bang yeah i'm
excited for some alarm free living i've
been sleeping so well this week me too
and the alarm has just been coming from
my neck you know you're sleeping and i'm
just hoping that my good sleeps carry
into tomorrow because it's like on the
weekends i sleep like trash so i'm just
hoping whatever i've been doing i'm
gonna follow the same routine and just
hope that it carries me into the weekend
you know you're sleeping good when your
alarm clock doesn't wake you up it
becomes the soundtrack of your dream
yeah no but like i've just it's been
uninterrupted i finally like figured out
how how i should be sleeping like in
pregnancy like pillows tucked in under
me that's gonna like support my back
more and so i'm just like in this cocoon
and i just need it to carry over to
alarm free living that's all i need yeah
that's a thing it's like by the time
friday rolls around your body's like
kind of used to waking up at like eight
so then by saturday your body's like
wait i thought we were waking up by
eight i'm like body shut the [ __ ] up and
go back to sleep yeah you know nothing
how do you not know how this works 29
years on it's five and two five and two
well for us sometimes it's four and
three you know maybe your body's not
used to our hectic schedule it is quite
hectic also this weekend is daylight
savings so oh yeah make sure to set your
clocks back so we get a 25-hour birthday
yes i do that's crazy and we get an
extra hour of sleep this weekend
but we're entering the dark ages i know
so but you know what like i literally
never leave my house so like it doesn't
matter also update i'm seeing an
apartment today the one that you sent me
i know you don't like love it and
honestly it doesn't solve the problem of
the bunker like because it still like
doesn't have great views no but it's a
great apartment and a great location so
i'm gonna go look at it yeah i was
actually after you sent me that
i went to do my some of my own research
due diligence and it's just like what
you're looking for doesn't exist it
doesn't exist and if it does you sure
can't afford it no i know and
i don't know what to tell you um it's
just making your apartment look better
and better no you know what everything
in my apartment now like that now that
i've like given up everything's broken i
know you told us that and everything's
sad i don't want to fix it i just i
really want to move like i really really
do
i just
i'm worried i'm worried about what i'm
seeing i didn't i ran my own street easy
searches and it was bleak
very yeah maybe you should just move in
with me
sure i would like to do we go
wife swap but like we'll send the
husbands to my house oh my god that's so
funny brew and dew could be roomies oh
my god broomies
too cute
and you know what else we have to
acknowledge the space that we're in we
are
coming on our final show of the week
with still very good stories it has been
almost five days it's been a strong week
of
decent and above average stories we've
got a lot to discuss today the wicked
movie
there's stuff going on and i just want
to say thank you universe we are
grateful yeah and now i do feel like
this time of year
is a strong time of year you know the
summer lags
and like everything was lagging for two
years so i just feel like we're in a
strong place i feel really good about it
and i feel good about jumping right in i
do as do i so without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
modern fertility did you know that a
simple finger prick can unlock tons of
insight into your reproductive health
egg counts menopause timing your hormone
levels could indicate conditions like a
thyroid disorder or even pcos it's all
just good things to know
whether or not you see kids in your
future because there's so much about
fertility that's a complete mystery and
that's where the modern fertility
hormone test comes in think of your
fertility hormones as tiny detectives
they can bring tons of insight into your
medical
history your medical details um
so
modern fertility is a fabulous product
it's super super easy
to get the kit
and it's just also really important for
you to know things about your body so
the traditional testing if you go to a
doctor to get these types of insights it
can cost over a thousand dollars but
modern fertility is just getting you all
that same information for a hundred and
fifty nine dollars and also we have a
code for twenty dollars off at
fertility.com toast so it was created
the easy affordable way to test your
fertility hormones at home with a symbol
finger prick you'll mail it in with
their prepaid label and you get
personalized results within 10 days so
there again offering our listeners 20
off their already amazing price if you
go to
modernfertility.com toast that means
your test is gonna cost just 139
um
and you also get the 20 off don't forget
modernfertility.com toast wonderful
okay our first story you guys kanye
stands listen up
kanye west says he still wants to be
with quote my wife kim kardashian
so kanye went on revel tv's drink champs
the episode just dropped in a new
interview he's talking about the divorce
everything he says he still quote wants
to be with a strange estranged wife kim
despite their ongoing divorce
proceedings in the new interview he uh
blasted snl for its portrayal of their
breakup and admitted he wants to
reconcile he said quote snl making my
wife say i divorced him on tv because
they just wanted to get that bar off i
never even seen the papers were not even
divorced i just want to say i don't
think snl made kim say anything i think
everything she said she stood behind i'm
sorry like just want that to go on the
record i know she was like involved in
writing her monologue with all these
different comedians so i don't think
anyone was forced to say anything but
continue he said they ain't no joke to
me my kids want their parents to stay
together i want us to be together he
also blamed the media and kim's own team
for promoting the idea of divorce and
getting into the reality star's ear with
ideas of new tv shows he said there's
this publicist that's nice to her i
don't [ __ ] with her i don't want i do
not want over our house and i don't [ __ ]
with some of them nannies either oh my
god do you think she he's talking about
tracy romulus
i don't think so she's been such a
friend of the family for so long
no because that's not a publicist that's
nice to her that's like kim's closest
friend right and publicist yes but i
think kim has many publicists of course
you know you got to look at it from all
angles i mean this is like sad because
i've already gotten used to the idea of
like them not being together and like
her dating but you know it wouldn't it
wouldn't be a terrible end to this story
if like she got to date a little bit and
then they eventually got back together
yeah that's where i'm at right now like
i would love to see them get back
together but i'm also loving single kim
and like we know that he was with irena
and i feel like for a long time in the
marriage you know he wasn't where she
needed him to be and be there for her so
like right now she gets to do kim tings
and then maybe once they've both had
their fill they can come back together
but i love that he's not giving up on
them um i do agree like snl was just
like so toxic no kidding i also think
that
while he may be saying this publicly
it's very possible that like
what went on between them is
irreconcilable you know like it's easy
to say this but kim may be hearing this
interview and being like what the [ __ ]
maybe but she's never portrayed that
it's something irreconcilable like it's
from and i'm sure there's more that we
don't know but it really seemed like
you know he moved to wyoming like he
wasn't there for her this isn't a
marriage like she wants more from her
life
yeah and that's what she deserves right
but that's not like irreconcilable
differences something so crazy happened
that they can't come back from
no i think maybe like he losing his wife
and
his kids half the time like has made him
realize like okay if that means that i
spend less time in wyoming like i will
choose kim over wyoming and he is
selling his house there i know it just
feels like okay now connie has come to
this realization but like for kim like
it could be too late like what about all
this time i literally spent by myself
with the kids like this like just
because kanye is now might have been
woken up to like the fact that he wasn't
being a good husband doesn't mean kim is
just gonna like jump back into it no and
i don't think that she should because i
think maybe you know she would always be
like well what if so i think she needs
to enjoy this time but knowing that
kanye's there waiting for her i think
must be feel really good and for the
fans like i i would love to see it i
don't know i'm really just like in this
headspace now where it's like okay
they're done you're done you're done
like
i'm ready for
a new chapter i am i think that they're
gonna
see the rest of the world and realize
like there's just no one on their level
except for the two of them well that's
true it is very difficult to date like
in your
like social circle when your social
circle is like literally full of five
people
that and also like they really are two
of the smartest people i think at least
the smartest people like i
follow and engage with and i think you
know she can have all the fun she wants
but like no one's gonna keep her on her
toes like kanye no but i think the some
of the keeping on the toes is what like
was
you know she wants to be on the ground
right yeah but you know she's a solid
girl like she is she's very stable she
like doesn't drink she doesn't really
party she's like works family like her
values are so clear
and you know in hollywood it's hard to
find someone with those values someone
who doesn't want to go out and thirst
they just want to work sleep family pray
like i think that's going to be
difficult for her to find i really do
and so we wait and see but i think this
is all good news i hope connie is doing
okay though you know if he's like
watching kim
it must be very challenging but like
again i totally forgot he dated irena
like he's also participating in this
unless it's separation unless it was
business stop it's oh it could be
business stop
you don't know you never saw a picture
of them kissing stop like seriously why
what are they gonna do why why does it
hurt you if i want to think it was
because
because what are they going into
business on i never saw a product maybe
she's gonna model for him maybe like a
million things he's she's in fashion
he's in fashion wouldn't we have seen
the byproduct of that working
relationship kanye works years in
advance on things got it he's working on
like this
concepts that are decades off okay well
i guess we'll have to wait a decade to
see if they were actually dating or i
don't know why you can't like why it
because it offends you so today because
they might need to be realistic we need
to be realistic i think that that's not
really that crazy i don't think you
would hang out like privately like so
much with someone you're working with
it's just not proper business like
we do we're related we we're in business
we are sisters always together because
of the business
no we're always together because we're
literally came out of the same vagina
like no i don't see the other sisters as
much yeah one of them lives in florida
and the other hates us
bachelor come back stature please we
love you like we know you're so cool but
like hang out with your sisters like
we're cool too by the way we're so cool
we are i wanted to argue that we're
cooler than some of the people that
marvel hangs out with like why wouldn't
you hang out with us like we could give
her a clout 100 we have the biggest show
in massachusetts in 2017. yeah no please
counts come back to us like i'm a
touring comedian tickets available at
girl no job.com tour we need counseling
desperately
are you ready for our next story a
little more family drama is it the anna
ferris of it all yeah this is so bizarre
okay chris pratt is getting slammed for
praising his wife and their quote
healthy child in a new instagram post
caption i want to read the caption
verbatim and then we'll explain why it's
weird where the alleged nefariousness
comes in we're the alleged nefari is
that a word no i don't think so i think
it should be like the nefariousness the
new parody okay he posted a picture of
the two of them where she's him and his
new wife catherine schwarzenegger where
she's smiling looking at him and he said
guys for real look how she's looking at
me i mean find you somebody that looks
like you looks at you like that you know
we met in church she's giving me an
amazing life a gorgeous healthy daughter
she shoes so loudly that sometimes i put
in my earbuds to drown it out et cetera
et cetera et cetera key word here is
gorgeous healthy daughter because so i
want to say when i first saw the post
i'm like that is so sweet like i thought
nothing nefarious was going on yeah no
it is a sweet post where he's just
adoring his wife
but the anna faris stands and just you
know fans in general are calling him out
because his son with anna ferris jack
has suffered health issues over the
years and anna faris has been like very
public about it yes so people think that
this healthy daughter comment is a dig
like that so
yeah like it's a slight towards anna
paris and they're yeah
and saying like catherine gave me a
healthy daughter whereas someone else
perhaps did not so i want to say before
we really dive in i don't think it's
uncommon to phrase like you know what
look at my lovely wife she gave me four
beautiful healthy children i don't think
that that's an uncommon thing to say
just in general it's not like he made
this up people do say that right do you
agree yes yes okay
so there's that
but there's also the elephant in the
room which is their other child who has
experienced health issues
and it's really hard to like know that
see this and not think something
nefarious is going on like it's a dig
okay so i
in looking inward and really thinking
about if chris pratt is capable of
writing something so evil and disgusting
like that i have to give him the benefit
of that i know and
say like i don't think the two things
are related i really don't i i can see i
see how
when you put them together how it looks
how it looks
but
i can't imagine that he is using this
opportunity to take a dig at his ex-wife
and his he's still jack is as much his
child as it is anna's health i really
can't believe that someone could do that
i don't want to believe it like and
especially because like chris pratt what
we know of him he's not a bad guy right
he's a nice guy he's like america's
sweetheart like i wouldn't say america's
sweetheart i think there's been like
rumors that he's like a little bit of a
dick but again not a crime and i don't
think that means you're gonna publicly
drag your kid for his health problems
that are out of his control a hundred
percent i
i've gotta believe
that this is just an awful coincidence
and i can believe that it's an awful
coincidence only because what i
previously stated
is that this is not an uncommon thing
for a man to praise his wife for like
you know if you're at your 50th
anniversary with zach and he's like
jackie you're this amazing woman gave me
four beautiful healthy children i don't
know why i keep saying four but you know
what i mean it is a thing people say
it's not uncommon it's not this is not a
phrase i've never heard it wasn't like a
random adjective he decided to throw in
yeah
so i think that optics wise he might
have been able to see this coming um but
not if he really had no bad intentions
right no he only would have seen it
coming if he thought about it and then
he wouldn't have posted it and as far as
i know the chris pratt
anna faris
catherine schwarzenegger like trio
is like a decent co-parenting situation
is it not i don't know there's something
nefarious going on there 100
but i'm not up on
on the trio like other people are no
people are like obsessed with this crew
and people are obsessed with analytics
she's a podcaster so she has like
podcast energy behind her um and then
like catherine and chris are just like
so in love and yeah moved on so annoying
but anna also has a man's so i don't
know
yeah whenever i think of anna faris i
just
my friend abe when we were in college
pointed out that if you swap the eye and
anapharis to a t it's anna farts and
every time i say her name i almost say
hannah farts oh that's that's so funny i
actually love anaphary like as an
actress she is
one of the measure be one of my tops yet
when i saw her and watch what happens
live remember she did um
i think she did one of the la live shows
like a few years ago oh i don't remember
that and it was just like
it was not the vibe for me why what was
the vibe it was just a little
maybe she was just in a bad spot but it
was just all over the place speaking of
watch weapons live yesterday i did catch
up and i saw sierra and paige on watch
robin's live and andy asked so many
questions about paige
about craig dupage and she was
so like i just she like stood by her man
like in the you know he's like shady
questions like who's a better kisser
andrea andrea or craig and she was like
craig isn't better at everything like
she was just like really like defending
her man to andy's like shady questions
and she was handling it so well and like
it was so cute like i shipped so [ __ ]
hard oh my god that's
amazing news yeah and they were both oh
my god looking
like this is a level of two gorgeous
girls like actually that makes me never
want to leave my house again like you
never saw two people so effortlessly
stunning like it's actually unfair a
couple of snatchers literally literally
wow okay so i personally i'm gonna give
chris pratt the benefit of the doubt
here so am i but i would love to hear in
the comments what you guys think because
people do not wish him the best i know i
know people don't agree with me and i
just when i went to read his instagram
caption i thought that maybe he might
have changed it out
but it's still there which i think goes
to like if he took it out it would mean
you know it's admitting like i killed i
[ __ ] up so i think just like leaving
it like i said what i said i meant
nothing more than what i said
and moving on yeah i don't know if you
can talk about like meeting your wife in
church in the same caption as like
dissing your son's health issues i just
i don't see it
i don't see it the whole caption is just
like a love letter to his wife like he i
don't think he threw a dig to his other
to his son in there yeah i i
i don't think so i i really can't i
can't believe it like you know it's so
unbelievable yeah it's un like i just
don't believe in that level of cruelty
from that it exists like even in
hollywood like i just can't remember
that it exists just like on a regular
thursday night like i just can't i
refuse yeah okay
are you ready for our next story that's
brought to you by curology curology
customizes a prescription formula with
three active ingredients picked for you
to help tackle your skincare needs
whether that's taking control of acne
fine lines dark spots breakouts clogged
pores you start by answering questions
online about your skin and if it's a
good fit then curology will match you
with a licensed dermatology provider who
will get to know your skin and subject
to consultation you'll get a customized
prescription cream to be shipped
straight to your door to address your
acne fine lines dark spots and more yes
i did this i'm actually on my second um
round of curology and first of all the
consultation is very in-depth you have
to send like a million pictures of your
face answer tons of questions and it's
nice because like you know you have your
problems i have mine like we should not
be using the same skin care curology is
like so personal
more personal than comedy
um
and you can start your curology journey
just like we did with a free 30-day
trial at curology.com toast if you're
prescribed just pay five dollars for
shipping and handling at curology.com
toast that's c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com toast to unlock your free 30-day
trial cancel anytime go get that glow
great okay our next story the musical
event of truth
actually that's also the next story too
but ariana grande and cynthia arrivo
will star in the wicked musical for
universal
they will portray glinda and alphabet
ariana is playing glinda cynthia's
playing alphabet respectively in
universal's big screen adaptation of the
tony winning musical helmed by in the
heights director john m chu he has been
attached to the project since february
and casting rumors for the film's two
main roles have been swirling for months
on thursday night these two confirm
their roles and their excitement okay so
this wicked movie i'm like afraid
because there's nothing i want to see
more but it's been like cursed like they
announced on twitter like the wicked
movie in 2016. like it's been like this
long there's like a whole conspiracy
theory about it if you want to look into
it what's it what's giving the gist so
like like that it's a aka never coming
like okay i know that people have been
cast but like it's literally been years
and years and years they announced like
coming in 2017 never came but what's the
conspiracy i don't know you'll have to
look into it i'm not sure like is there
is it a front no not a front but like
just that it's never coming it's like
this ethereal thing that's never gonna
actually happen okay and now that we've
been cast like i think we're inching
towards that actually happening which
i'm very grateful for and i actually
don't think i could have chosen two
better people for each role i mean
glinda is so obviously ariana grande for
a million reasons just because
ariana grande is obsessed with and like
really mentored by kristin chenoweth who
was the original glinda she's such a
musical theater nerd a lot of people
don't know she started her career in 13
on broadway she's obsessed with show
tunes she performed in that wicked 10th
anniversary special where she delivered
one of the most gorgeous unbelievable
stunning performances of the wizard and
i it was she was being alphabet i know
and i do think her vocal range is more
alphabet but her personality wise and
like
physically she's so glinda i actually
think that her vocal range is pretty
glindex it's like
ethereal yes but it's also belty she can
hit every note possible and that is
alphabet yeah she could do both she
could have gotten either part i think
also do you remember like a million
years ago she released a song with micah
do you remember that guy micah popular
yeah she has been obsessed with wicked
her whole life and so like to see
someone
realizing their dreams something they
obviously manifested is so gorgeous and
stunning and like you have no choice but
to stand yeah i'm extremely here for
this movie for this casting i think if
it's done well like it could be you know
ari's oscar moment oh my god
so i'm very very excited and then let's
talk about the cynthia arrivo of it all
who i think is so weird because like
what we know her for is acting when
she's literally in my opinion like one
of the greatest voices out there and
she's not really like
career-wise a singer like i know she's
done theater but that's not what we know
her for and so when she performs at the
oscars
it was just
my jaw hit the floor yeah and elphaba
and her songs and her range like
requires the greatest singer it requires
like belly diaphragm belting like not
everyone can do that idina manziel can't
even do it anymore because no but like
at the time like edina
was that girl was that girl so i think
cynthia riva is going to knock it out of
the park i think i'm i'm so excited for
their excitement for the project yeah
and i just hope you know everyone gets
to work soon and we can see it soon
because i don't like to wait long no me
neither and like people have literally
been talking about you know what hold on
if you go to the wicked movie twitter
maybe they i remember like two years ago
on twitter they announced like when the
movie was coming or something and then
the anniversary came up like a year ago
and like we never even heard about the
wicked movie so people were like quote
tweeting
okay wicked movie oh i think they they
don't have it anymore um so whatever
this is just a new leaf maybe they got
like new directions
the new directions and um
you know it's all starting anew let's
give them from today on yeah for sure
like i'm just
overwhelmed by this casting it's giving
me the way we felt about annie live and
their stellar casting this is that times
100. yeah i agree
are you well done
the next musical event of the actual tis
the season annie kelly clarkson
announces a christmas special featuring
ariana grande queen once again leslie
odom jr and more so kelly clarkson will
be hosting kelly clarkson presents when
christmas comes around holiday
spectacular next month the special will
feature special guests including brett
eldredge wow ariana grande yes jay leno
by the way i watched the kelly clarkson
show yesterday or two days ago because
it was on i'm like you know what i've
never actually watched a show i was
watching it and i guess kelly's on
vacation and jay leno was filling in for
her i think jay leno's like a big kelly
clarkson girl i mean how could he not be
yep
melissa mccarthy
leslie odom jr amy poehler and santa
claus of course of course there will
probably be duets and also you know
people checking in it's giving me a very
crazy casey christmas yeah and which was
perfection served it was splatter
gorgeous so i'm so excited for this it
will be on nbc on december 1st and then
two days later is annie live oh i think
it's on peacock like something actually
helpful no it will be on the end i'm
sure eventually it'll be on peacock but
i just know your girl will be watching
live how kelly has really in a really
organic cool authentic way like brenda
herself is like one of the many pillars
in this in hollywood like of christmas i
think mariah carey is doing it in a very
like obvious and borderline annoying way
um like every you know her brand for the
last three years has been like i'm the
christmas girl but it's like she became
the christmas girl when did that song
come out like 20 years ago yeah and it's
only like three years ago her team
realized that we should lead into it
wait we own christmas right so now it's
like become a parody of itself and it's
like a little stupid she's unfreezing
yeah she's breaking the pumpkin this
year like yadda yadda so now it's like
but kelly's coming in an organic way
right as just like a christmas file a
holiday file a holiday file and she's
bringing in her friends and her
co-workers and they're just gonna
celebrate and she's so great because she
really bridges so many genres like she
is a pop star but she is such deep roots
in nashville you know she was married to
reba's stepson forever and so she's just
like very much in has a foot in both
worlds and she could bring a brett
eldridge and she could pull an ariana
grande and like that's why we stan a
queen who is so universal we really
really do i mean it's not a week at the
morning toast if we're not showing kelly
some love no we had been quiet this week
previously and i meant to tell you that
i watched a kelly clarkson show actually
leah michelle was on and emily osment um
separately but they like sat on the
couch together to discuss their likes to
bring people together yeah and then lea
michelle performed like a really weird
stripped-down version of sweet child of
mine like a cover
i just feel like when you go on a
daytime show like and you perform like
you're
promoting a new song or something like
it was a weird performance um and i'm
not gonna lie i i sensed uh a brokenness
in leah michelle i think like she's
fallen so far in this last year and when
she was like sitting like talking to
emily osmond and jay leno i just felt
like i'm like she does not want to be
here like i just could sense there was
something in her that was no longer
there you know interesting and now that
i think about it when i was reading the
wicked casting i was like i don't know
who i had in mind or who i would have
even cast but now like
totally that's also what happened from
funny girl podcast i think that like
honestly her cancellation couldn't have
come at a worse time for her
professionally with these two projects
floating around like i'm sure her name
was thrown into the conversations it had
to have been for me for um fanny price
and it had to have been for wicked well
i think for wicked it's less glaring
because like these like
cynthia and ari are
amazing choices period um it's less
glaring yes 100 but for funny girl and i
know like okay so she had this
cancellation of bullying and like that
she can't read and um
but like
at the end of the day it should be about
the talent like especially for broadway
like
michelle
would be the best fanny price like she
should be famous i agree actually and i
don't know beanie's broadway abilities
i'm sure they're huge because she's
friends with ben platt and i'm sure
she'll be great but i agree and like we
also need to get a little perspective on
the whole leah michelle thing because
like people just love to hate her when
her crimes were white when she was on
glee she was like a [ __ ] because she
got really famous and she was nasty to
everyone on set which no one should be
and i'm not excusing that but like what
her whole life should be ruined because
of it like let's get some perspective
she didn't run anyone over with her car
like so i agree with the with the fanny
bryce thing and i don't think i don't
think even if it weren't for the
cancellation would she have gotten
alphabet her name was definitely thrown
around especially because like when i
think of a young adina menzel i think of
lea michelle because of glee adina
mendel actually played leah's mom like
so it is like obvious to me me in that
sense but i think that's just because
i'm a die-hard gleek yeah no and i think
cynthia arrivo being in it with ari
brings it to a whole other level agreed
as opposed to was like leah michelle and
ari yeah that gives it like a
made-for-tv ryan murphy thing like teeny
popper yeah
no cynthia revo like really elevates
this [ __ ] yeah in a theatrical
broad way like it brings all the
credibility so
i'm cool with it yeah but i am thinking
of leah no me too i'm really thinking of
her during this difficult time because
now she's out here promoting like the
original cast of spring awakening is
doing a not a revival a reunion like on
like like it's like an event a one-night
thing like and that's what she's out
here promoting when like she could have
all these other projects like you know
yeah it is weird yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
not yet
but we will be
it's the final story
[Music]
[Music]
our thoughts and prayers
jackhammer yes today's jackhammer is
brought to you by zocdoc has this ever
happened to you you need to see a doctor
you search and find one that looks good
you wait hold book an appointment
rearrange your schedule and then the
doctor doesn't even take your insurance
well let me introduce you to zocdoc the
free app
the easiest way to find a great doctor
and instantly book an appointment
because with zocdoc you can search for
local doctors who take your insurance
read verified patient reviews and book
an appointment in person or on video
chat never wait on hold with a
receptionist again whether you need a
primary care physician a dentist a
dermatologist psychiatrist eye doctor or
other specialist zocdoc has got you
covered go to zocdoc.com
toast and download the zoc doc app to
sign up for free every month millions of
people use zocdoc and we're one of them
it's our go-to whenever we need to see a
doctor if you don't know um like a
specialist in your area it's actually
really hard to find ones that are
recommended and zoc talk just
streamlines the entire process for you
now is the time to prioritize your
health go to zocdoc.com toast and
download the zoc doc app
to sign up for free and book a top rated
doctor many are available that's
z-o-c-d-o-c dot com slash toast thank
you should we um
should we let's just we're getting a
fifth and final story and then we're out
okay like the jack hiring is annoying me
i don't know if people can hear it i
think they probably could feel the
vibration i'm sure you're feeling some
good vibrations
yeah let's pause it's really [ __ ]
annoying i don't think they're gonna
stop
like just meet our mics
please
okay what is the fifth and final story
jax siesta keys chloe troutman is
engaged to boyfriend chris long and
she's showing off her ring which is
quite unusual and quite unique yeah it's
really pretty but i was also really
shocked because i haven't really been
keeping up with the siesta key crew and
last i knew she was dating that guy from
denver who's brunette and then she's
engaged and now this guy's blonde how
long have they been together
i'm not sure but she announced on
thursday the couple got engaged at bryce
canyon national park in utah while
sharing photos from the romantic moments
she revealed how he proposed she said
yesterday i said yes to my soul mate in
fairyland chris took us on an 8.2 mile
loop trail that was the hardest torture
i've ever done in my life mentally and
physically the emotional release after
finishing this hike was indescribable as
i was standing at the overlook
reflecting over over all the emotions i
felt throughout this hike i heard chris
say my name and i turned around and
there he was down on one knee okay
that's like oh that's a journey but it's
actually like really beautiful yeah um
but imagine like feeling all of those
feelings of
accomplishing a hike literally i know
not for you
not for you this is a rough way and then
you're all sweaty like not my ideal
engagement honestly no no no and i i
wouldn't suggest it for you i wouldn't
tell ben to
get any ideas but i'm just saying like
that must be a very much like an
emotional rollercoaster yeah like you in
accomplish this personal milestone and
then you turn around and like there's
another milestone waiting for you and
it's all very exciting so this is really
sweet um she keeps her relationships
pretty
close
yeah even on the show she's never like
really in a relationship we've never
seen any of her boyfriends really but
they became instagram official in may
and now it's
so they were probably dating before that
yeah they've probably been dating like
about a year or a little bit less
cute i'm happy for her she's such a nice
girl and really wishing her the best
this is her moment yeah i'm happy for
her too i really love her ring it's very
um different middleton yeah with green
that's an emerald right uh i think so i
don't know my stones me neither but not
well no kate middleton has an emerald no
blue sapphire oh yeah green is emerald
right that would make sense emerald city
is green and wicked that would make
sense but ruby is red
i don't know if it's that
straightforward it's very confusing no i
think it is stone tangs are very
confusing stone too and i'm glad to see
like a little good news in a national
park you love to see it yes it's been
such a bad year for national parks and
that's that on that yeah thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please shut the [ __ ] up
and please leave a five star review
about our beautiful stunning and where
we are hope you guys have an amazing
weekend thank you so much for a great
week of morning toast episodes we will
see you back here on monday have a great
weekend and drop an uh
emoji on our most face on instagram
something that makes you feel inspired i
have nothing to do some construction
emojis yes maybe a traffic cone maybe
one of those you know yield signs i like
that that's good you guys have a great
day and weekend bye